[Music]  welcome to our playing one-minute chests  at the office with few spectators some  trash-talking trying to make this look  cool without further ado we got our  entire Grand Master we've got lucious  Cuyahoga trying to be a master or at  least used to be trying to be Grand  Master please go ahead and start  [Music]  looks like the rehearse this stuff  that's not how your castle I can't see  the clock but looks like people are  playing fairly fast and fairly well  Marshall Sabbath that was strange  finally occupies that wonderful square  new for and now lush this car is stuck  gotta be faster this marriage salvaged  classical planner and its shores but  it's kind of sweater up some trouble you  can't  no scar at 24 seconds RN at 28 that's  our head of streaming also no head of  clocks Chef Scott is trying for the  perpetual I'm just not going to  perpetual mrs. Rooke now decides to give  it up no style points  [Music]